Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca
油砂开采对加拿大的碳排放有着显著影响。因此，六家最大的公司携手合作，在迈向净零排放的道路上大步迈进。他们投资于技术与创新，使每桶石油的平均排放量已经减少了22%。他们与政府合作，创造并保护工作岗位，并正在开发世界上最大的碳捕集与封存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在实施中，我们正通过多种途径取得进展。请访问 pathwaysalliance.ca 查看我们的行动计划。
Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Due to the nature of this crime, K-Spile has elected to change the names of several individuals featured in this episode. In April of 2004, teenager Laura Fletcher had recently celebrated her 18th birthday. She was in the final months of her senior year of high school and was set to graduate as one of the top 10 students in her class. An avid painter and photographer, Laura took advanced art lessons to further her creative skills. But her main ambition was to study pre-med at the University of Louisville in her home state of Kentucky so she could later attend medical school.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得自己需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关获得保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用上或我们网站上本期节目的shownotes。由于这起犯罪的性质，K-Spile选择更改本期节目中几位当事人的姓名。2004年4月，十几岁的劳拉·弗莱彻刚刚庆祝了她18岁的生日。她当时正处于高中高三的最后几个月，并准备以班级前10名的优异成绩毕业。作为一个热爱绘画和摄影的人，劳拉上了高级美术课来提升自己的创意技能。但她最大的志向是在家乡肯塔基州的路易斯维尔大学攻读医学预科，以便日后进入医学院深造。
Laura's reputation for being responsible and well-behaved extended outside of school hours. She attended church regularly and had previously been a Girl Scout. When her mother's health issues led to her losing her job, Laura offered to help support her family. In January 2004, she got a part-time job at a local McDonald's fast food restaurant near her home in Mount Washington. Earning $6.35 an hour, Laura was a reliable employee who was always willing to help out by taking on extra shifts. At around 4.45pm on Friday, April 9, Laura was preparing to head home after finishing an afternoon shift. Before she left, her manager asked if she could stay a little longer to cover for another employee who had just called in sick. Friday evenings were always busy and the restaurant couldn't afford to be understaffed.
劳拉负责任和表现良好的名声不仅体现在学校。她经常去教堂，以前还是一名女童子军。当母亲的健康问题导致母亲失业时，劳拉主动提出帮助养家糊口。2004年1月，她在离位于华盛顿山的家不远的一家当地麦当劳快餐店找到了一份兼职工作。劳拉的时薪为6.35美元，是一名可靠的员工，总是乐意通过多上几个班来帮忙。4月9日星期五下午4点45分左右，劳拉刚上完下午的班，正准备回家。在她离开之前，她的经理问她是否能多待一会儿，顶替一个刚刚打电话说生病的员工。星期五的晚上总是很忙，餐厅经不起人手不足的折腾。
Laura would only have to stay until someone else could be found to work the entire shift. Happy to help and eager for the chance to earn a little extra money, Laura agreed to continue working. McDonald's employees who worked a double shift were given a free meal to tide them over, so Laura took a short break to eat before returning behind the counter. Also working that night was 51-year-old Donna Summers, one of the restaurant's assistant managers. Like Laura, Summers was relatively new to the franchise. She had only been working there for about 8 months. Just as Laura returned to serving customers, the restaurant's phone rang at 4.56pm. Summers answered it. On the other end was a man who identified himself as a police officer named Officer Scott. Officer Scott explained that he had McDonald's corporate on another line, as well as Lisa Siddons, the store's manager.
劳拉只需要呆到能找到其他人来上整个班为止。劳拉很乐意帮忙，也很渴望有赚点外快机会，于是她同意继续工作。上双班的麦当劳员工可以得到一顿免费餐食以度过这段时间，因此劳拉在回到柜台后面之前休息了一会儿吃东西。当晚也在工作的还有51岁的唐娜·萨默斯，她是餐厅的助理经理之一。和劳拉一样，萨默斯对这家连锁店来说也比较新。她才在那里工作了大约8个月。就在劳拉回去为顾客服务时，餐厅的电话在下午4点56分响了。萨默斯接了电话。电话那头是一个自称是名叫斯科特警官的男子。斯科特警官解释说，他另一条线路上有麦当劳公司的人，还有该店的经理丽莎·西多恩斯。
He was calling because a child who had been in the restaurant earlier had her coin purse stolen. The culprit was believed to be one of Summers employees. He provided a physical description of the suspect, young, white and female, with a petite build and dark hair. She was wearing a McDonald's uniform. Officer Scott also described a tie that the suspect was wearing. Summers immediately thought of Laura Fletcher. Even though her work record was exemplary, she'd fit the suspect's description perfectly. While leaving Officer Scott waiting on the phone, Summers found Laura and asked her to accompany her to the manager's office at the back of the restaurant. The small, cramped room had a tiled floor with a desk and a countertop running against opposing walls. Their surfaces were crowded with a computer and various items of stationery.
他打电话是因为一个早些时候在餐厅里的小孩的零币钱包被偷了。罪魁祸首被认为是萨默斯的员工之一。他提供了嫌疑人的体貌特征：年轻、白人、女性，身材娇小，留着深色头发。她穿着麦当劳制服。斯科特警官还描述了嫌疑人系的一条领带。萨默斯立刻想到了劳拉·弗莱彻。尽管她的工作记录无可挑剔，但她完全符合嫌疑人的描述。在让斯科特警官在电话那头等候的同时，萨默斯找到了劳拉，并请她陪自己去餐厅后面的经理办公室。这个狭小拥挤的房间里铺着瓷砖地板，一张桌子和一个操作台沿着相对的墙壁延伸。它们的表面挤满了电脑和各种文具用品。
A filing cabinet sat to one side and boxes were stacked beneath the bench top. Perched up high in the ceiling was a CCTV camera. Summers led Laura into the manager's office before locking the door behind them. She then informed Laura that a police officer had accused her of robbing a customer. Shocked, Laura immediately protested her innocence, telling her manager, Donna, I've never done anything wrong. I could never steal. Summers responded that a police officer had described Laura as the person responsible. Officer Scott was still waiting on the phone.
一个文件柜放在一侧，长椅下方堆放着箱子。天花板高处安装着一个闭路电视摄像头。萨默斯把劳拉领进经理办公室，然后把门锁上。接着她告知劳拉，一名警官指控她抢劫了一名顾客。劳拉大吃一惊，立即抗议自己的清白，对经理唐娜说：“我从来没有做错过任何事。我绝不可能偷东西。”萨默斯回答说，一名警官描述劳拉就是那个应该负责的人。斯科特警官还在电话那头等着。
Summers switched between speaking to him and Laura. Officer Scott informed Summers that Laura had two choices. She could either submit to a search for the stolen purse then and there, or she could wait until an officer came to arrest her and undergo a search at the police station. Upon learning of her options, Laura started to cry and to beg to be taken to the police station so the matter could be cleared up there. Summers handed the phone to Laura, who spoke to Officer Scott herself. After doing so, Laura agreed to be searched on the spot.
萨默斯在与他和劳拉交谈之间切换。斯科特警官通知萨默斯，劳拉有两个选择。要么她当场接受搜查以找回被偷的钱包，要么她等警察来逮捕她并在警察局接受搜查。得知自己的选择后，劳拉哭了起来，并哀求带她去警察局，以便在那里把事情弄清楚。萨默斯把电话递给劳拉，劳拉亲自和斯科特警官对话。在此之后，劳拉同意当场接受搜查。
Officer Scott issued instructions to Summers, who in turn relayed them to Laura. First, Laura was asked to empty her pockets. She did so without complaint. After handing over her keys and her cell phone, Laura revealed there was no stolen purse in her pockets. Officer Scott suspected that the item could be hidden underneath Laura's clothing and ordered her to undress. By this time, another assistant manager named Kim Dockery arrived to start work. Kim was set to replace Summers for the evening shift. Upon discovering what was happening in the manager's office, Kim asked what was going on. Summers refused to say, at Officer Scott's command.
斯科特警官向萨默斯下达了指示，萨默斯随后转达给劳拉。首先，劳拉被要求清空她的口袋。她毫无怨言地照做了。在交出钥匙和手机后，劳拉透露她的口袋里没有被偷的钱包。斯科特警官怀疑物品可能藏在劳拉的衣服下面，并命令她脱衣服。此时，另一位名叫金·多克里的助理经理赶来上班。金将接替萨默斯上晚班。发现经理办公室里发生的事情后，金问发生了什么事。遵照斯科特警官的命令，萨默斯拒绝透露。
As Summers and Kim looked on, Laura reluctantly removed her McDonald's uniform one piece at a time until she stood in nothing but her underwear. She covered her face and cried, while Summers inspected each garment closely and shook each of them out. There was no sign of the stolen purse in Laura's clothing. She was then instructed to remove her underwear and surrender that as well. Laura was now completely naked. As Summers queried the validity of the accusation against Laura, Officer Scott made a startling statement. He told Summers that Laura was also being investigated for using and to dealing drugs.
在萨默斯和金的注视下，劳拉不情愿地一件接一件地脱掉麦当劳制服，直到她身上只剩下内衣。她捂着脸哭泣，而萨默斯则仔细检查每一件衣服并把它们抖落。劳拉的衣服里没有发现被偷钱包的迹象。接着她被指示脱下内衣并一并交出来。劳拉现在完全一丝不挂了。当萨默斯质疑针对劳拉的指控是否属实，斯科特警官发表了一个令人震惊的声明。他告诉萨默斯，劳拉还因吸毒和贩毒而受到调查。
Police officers were currently searching her family home in nearby Taylorsville. Consequently, Laura's clothes and other belongings were considered evidence in the drug investigation. Officer Scott told Summers to place them all inside a bag and leave them in her car so that he could collect them shortly. Summers did as she was told. Kim Dockery hugged Laura and tried to comfort her, stating, If this was happening to my daughter, I'd be pissed. She handed Laura an apron so that she could cover herself. As the restaurant was experiencing its peak hour, Kim returned to the restaurant floor.
警察目前正在搜查她位于附近泰勒斯维尔的家。因此，劳拉的衣服和其他随身物品被认为是毒品调查中的证据。斯科特警官告诉萨默斯把它们全部装进袋子里，留在她的车里，以便他稍后去收走。萨默斯照做了。金·多克里拥抱了劳拉并试图安慰她，说道：“如果这种事发生在我女儿身上，我会气疯的。”她递给劳拉一条围裙，以便她能遮住身体。由于餐厅正值客流高峰期，金回到了餐厅大厅。
Summers told Officer Scott that she also needed to get back to work. He requested that she find a male employee to watch over Laura until police arrived. Summers summoned Jason Bradley, a 27-year-old cook. She left him in the office with Laura and the telephone while she went back to her managerial duties in the restaurant. Laura held the apron against the front of her body as Jason faced away from her and spoke to Officer Scott. Upon learning that Laura was wearing nothing but an apron, Officer Scott told Jason to remove it and describe her body to him. This made Jason angry. After speaking with the officer for several minutes, he stormed out of the office and told Summers the entire matter was a lot of BS.
萨默斯告诉斯科特警官她也需要回去工作。他要求她找一个男员工来看守劳拉，直到警察到达。萨默斯叫来了27岁的厨师杰森·布拉德利。她把他和劳拉以及电话一起留在办公室里，自己则回到了餐厅履行经理职责。劳拉用围裙挡在身体前面，而杰森则背对她与斯科特警官交谈。得知劳拉只穿着一条围裙时，斯科特警官让杰森脱掉它并向他描述她的身体。这惹恼了杰森。与警官交谈了几分钟后，他冲出办公室，告诉萨默斯整件事全是一堆废话。
He flatly told her that he wanted no part of it before resuming his work in the kitchen. Summers didn't understand what Jason was upset about, so she resumed control of the phone. By now, it had been 40 minutes since she had answered Officer Scott's call. Summers explained that there was nobody else available to keep watch over Laura. In response, Officer Scott asked, Are you married? Summers giggled and informed the officer that she was actually engaged. When asked if she trusted her fiance, Summers said she did. Officer Scott queried whether Summers' fiance would be able to come to the restaurant to keep an eye on Laura.
他直截了当地告诉她，他不想参与其中，然后回到厨房继续工作。萨默斯不明白杰森为什么生气，于是她重新接管了电话。到目前为止，距离她接听斯科特警官的电话已经过去40分钟了。萨默斯解释说，没有其他人可以留下来看守劳拉。作为回应，斯科特警官问：“你结婚了吗？”萨默斯咯咯笑着告诉警官，她其实已经订婚了。当被问及她是否信任未婚夫时，萨默斯说她信任。斯科特警官追问萨默斯的未婚夫是否能来餐厅看守劳拉。
Summers agreed to call him and ask. Walter Nix Jr. was a 42-year-old father of two who worked as an exterminator. A churchgoing man who coached youth baseball teams, he was considered an upstanding member of the community. He and Donna Summers had only recently gotten engaged. Shortly before 6pm, Summers used her cell phone to call Nix. She explained that an employee was being investigated for theft and dealing drugs. When asked if he could help by keeping watch over her until police arrived, Nix agreed. He arrived at the McDonald's soon afterwards.
萨默斯同意打电话问问。沃尔特·尼克斯二世是一名42岁、育有两个孩子的父亲，职业是一名杀虫剂喷洒员。他是一个经常去教堂的人，曾执教青少年棒球队，被认为是社区里品行端正的成员。他和唐娜·萨默斯不久前刚刚订婚。晚上6点前不久，萨默斯用手机给尼克斯打电话。她解释说，一名员工正在因盗窃和贩毒而接受调查。当被问及他是否能帮忙看守她直到警察到来时，尼克斯同意了。不久后他来到了麦当劳。
Summers ushered her fiance to the manager's office, then left him alone with Laura and to the office phone. Laura was crying. She couldn't leave the office despite her desire to do so. Her only escape would be to run naked through the busy restaurant floor. She also felt physically intimidated by Nix, who was a foot taller than her and weighed 230 pounds. Laura stood with her back against one of the counters. Nix sat on a nearby swivel chair and spoke to Officer Scott, who identified himself as a detective. He requested that Nix remove Laura's apron and describe her body. Unlike Jason earlier, Nix did as asked.
萨默斯把未婚夫迎进经理办公室，然后把他和劳拉以及办公室电话单独留在里面。劳拉在哭。尽管她很想离开，但她不能离开办公室。她唯一的出路就是赤身裸体地穿过繁忙的餐厅大厅。她还对尼克斯感到身体上的威严恐吓，尼克斯比她高出一英尺，重230磅。劳拉背靠着其中一个柜台站着。尼克斯坐在附近的一把转椅上，与自称是侦探的斯科特警官交谈。他要求尼克斯脱掉劳拉的围裙并描述她的身体。与先前的杰森不同，尼克斯照做了。
He also began relaying other directions. Laura was made to stand on a chair and a desk so that she could be examined closely. Then she was ordered to perform star jumps to shake loose any items she might be concealing in or on her body. She was forced to run on the spot until she worked up a sweat. Officer Scott said that this would help determine what kind of drugs she had taken. He also had her bend over so that Nix could perform a cavity search. Every now and then, Nix would hand Laura the phone so she could speak to Officer Scott herself. The officer told Laura that if she wanted to keep her job, then she needed to cooperate.
他还开始传达其他指令。劳拉被强迫站在一张椅子和桌子上，以便对她进行仔细检查。然后她被命令做开合跳，以抖落她身上或体内可能藏匿的任何物品。她被迫在原地跑步，直到出了一身汗。斯科特警官说，这将有助于确定她吸食了哪种毒品。他还让她弯下腰，以便尼克斯可以进行腔内搜查。时不时地，尼克斯会把电话递给劳拉，以便她能亲自与斯科特警官对话。警官告诉劳拉，如果她想保住工作，她就需要配合。
Occasionally, Donna Summers or Kim Dockery entered the office. Nix alerted Officer Scott whenever they could be heard returning. In turn, he would tell Nix to stop what he was doing. Nix would throw the apron back at Laura and instruct her to be quiet. Laura did not tell Summers about the things she was being forced to do, but each time she saw her manager, she begged to be let go. By 6.50pm, Laura had been in the office with Nix for almost an hour. Officer Scott's demands were becoming increasingly distressing.
唐娜·萨默斯或金·多克里偶尔会进入办公室。每当听到他们回来的声音，尼克斯就会提醒斯科特警官。反过来，他会告诉尼克斯停下正在做的事。尼克斯会把围裙扔回给劳拉并命令她安静。劳拉没有把她被迫做的事情告诉萨默斯，但每次她看到经理时，她都哀求放她走。到晚上6点50分，劳拉和尼克斯在办公室里呆了将近一个小时。斯科特警官的要求变得越来越令人痛苦。
When Laura failed to address him as sir and continued to ask questions, Nix was ordered to spank her as punishment. While seated, Nix made Laura's life face down across his thighs and slapped her buttocks forcefully for almost 10 minutes. Large red waltz appeared on her skin. Throughout the beating, Laura begged Nix to stop. She told him that the orders were ridiculous. Her pleas only resulted in Nix hitting her more violently.
当劳拉没有称呼他为长官并继续提问时，尼克斯被命令打她屁股作为惩罚。坐着的时候，尼克斯让劳拉俯卧在自己大腿上，用力拍打她的臀部近10分钟。她的皮肤上出现了大片红肿。在殴打过程中，劳拉哀求尼克斯停下来。她告诉他，这些命令太荒谬了。她的恳求只导致尼克斯打得更狠。
The beating concluded at about 7.05pm. Several minutes later, Donna Summers returned to the office. Nix was seated and Laura was standing with her back to the corner nearest the computer. She had the apron covering her. When Summers moved close to get something, Laura quietly begged, Please get me out of here. Donna, please, please. I didn't do anything wrong. Please believe me. She asked Summers to call the police directly
殴打于晚上7点05分左右结束。几分钟后，唐娜·萨默斯回到办公室。尼克斯坐着，劳拉背靠着靠近电脑的角落站着。她用围裙遮住身体。当萨默斯走近去拿东西时，劳拉轻声哀求：“请带我离开这里。唐娜，求求你，求求你。我没有做错任何事。请相信我。”她请求萨默斯直接报警
but was told that they were still waiting for an officer to arrive. Summers then left the office. Nix and Laura were left alone once more. Officer Scott resumed his instructions. He told Nix to have Laura sit on his lap and give him a kiss so that he could smell anything that might be on her breath. Laura went numb and felt as though her soul left her body. Just before 7.30pm, Officer Scott demanded that Laura remove Nix's pants
但得到的回答是他们仍在等待警官到达。随后萨默斯离开了办公室。尼克斯和劳拉再次单独留在里面。斯科特警官恢复了指令。他告诉尼克斯让劳拉坐在他的膝盖上并给他一个吻，以便他能闻到她呼吸中可能有的任何气味。劳拉变得麻木，感觉灵魂仿佛出了壳。就在晚上7点30分之前，斯科特警官要求劳拉脱下尼克斯的裤子
and perform oral sex on him. She cried and pleaded with her captor stating, No, I didn't do anything wrong. This is ridiculous. Nix threatened to hit her again if she didn't do as Officer Scott ordered. Consequently, Laura was sexually assaulted yet again. Just over 10 minutes later at 7.52pm, Donna Summers re-entered the office to fetch some gift certificates. Laura was again cowering in the corner and Nix was standing.
并对他实施口交。她哭着向劫持者恳求道：“不，我没有做错任何事。这太荒谬了。”尼克斯威胁说，如果她不按照斯科特警官的命令去做，他就会再次打她。因此，劳拉再次遭到性侵犯。仅仅10分钟后，即晚上7点52分，唐娜·萨默斯再次进入办公室去取一些礼品券。劳拉再次蜷缩在角落里，尼克斯站着。
At Officer Scott's direction, he handed the phone back to Summers. Nix then left the restaurant and got in his car. He drove the few short blocks to his home. Once inside, he called a friend telling him, I have done something terribly bad. Meanwhile, Donna Summers was following Officer Scott's directive to find someone to replace Nix in the manager's office. She selected 58-year-old maintenance worker Thomas Sims.
在斯科特警官的指示下，他把电话交回给萨默斯。接着尼克斯离开餐厅上了车。他开车开了短短几个街区回到家里。一进屋，他就给一个朋友打电话说：“我做了一件非常糟糕的事。”与此同时，唐娜·萨默斯正在遵循斯科特警官的指令，找人接替尼克斯在经理办公室的位置。她挑选了58岁的维修工托马斯·西姆斯。
He wasn't rusted on that day and had just stopped by the restaurant to have a coffee and dessert. Summers asked Thomas to accompany her to the back office. Laura Fletcher was inside, attempting to conceal her naked body with a small apron. Shocked, Thomas took the phone and Summers left him alone with Laura. Officer Scott then ordered Thomas to remove Laura's apron and describe her body. He also asked repeatedly what Laura was doing with her hands. Thomas refused to comply and instead left to find Summers.
他那天没有排班，只是顺道来餐厅喝咖啡和吃甜点。萨默斯请托马斯陪她去后面的办公室。劳拉·弗莱彻在里面，试图用一条小围裙遮掩她赤裸的身体。托马斯大吃一惊，接过了电话，萨默斯把她和劳拉单独留在一起。接着斯科特警官命令托马斯脱掉劳拉的围裙并描述她的身体。他还反复询问劳拉双手在做什么。托马斯拒绝照办，而是离开去寻找萨默斯。
He told her what the caller was asking him to do and stated, Something is not right about this. Thomas demanded that Laura's clothes be returned to her and that someone call the police. Stunned by what Thomas had told her, Summers called the store manager Lisa Siddons. Officer Scott had been claiming that Lisa was on the other line for the entire duration of his call. Lisa answered the phone sounding tired. She had no idea what Summers was referring to and explained that she had been in bed sleeping. Summers became distraught and began begging Laura for forgiveness.
他把电话那头的人要求他做的事告诉了她，并说道：“这事有点不对劲。”托马斯要求把劳拉的衣服还给她，并要求有人报警。听到托马斯的话，萨默斯惊呆了，她打电话给店长丽莎·西多恩斯。斯科特警官一直声称丽莎在他的整个通话期间都在另一条线上。丽莎接起电话时听起来很累。她根本不知道萨默斯在说什么，并解释说她一直在床上睡觉。萨默斯变得心烦意乱，开始恳求劳拉的原谅。
Confused and concerned, Lisa headed to the restaurant. Once Summers realized she had been duped, the caller pretending to be Officer Scott hung up. Laura Fletcher's ordeal had gone on for almost three hours. Freezing cold and trembling in shock, she asked whether she would still need to work her shift the next day. Assistant manager Kim Dockery reassured Laura that she could take as much time off as she needed. She was given her clothes and allowed to dress. Meanwhile, Lisa Siddons and some of the restaurant's other employees arrived at the scene. The panicked McDonald's workers gathered in the manager's office.
困惑又担心的丽莎赶往餐厅。一旦萨默斯意识到自己被愚弄了，那个假冒斯科特警官的来电者就挂断了电话。劳拉·弗莱彻的折磨持续了近三个小时。她冻得浑身发抖，惊恐万状，她问自己第二天是否还需要去上班。助理经理金·多克里安慰劳拉说，她可以根据需要休假多长时间。她拿到了衣服并被允许穿上。与此同时，丽莎·西多恩斯和餐厅的其他一些员工赶到了现场。惊慌失措的麦当劳员工聚集在经理办公室里。
After discussing the matter amongst themselves, they called the police at around 9pm. As the Mount Washington police station was only a quarter of a mile away, officers arrived within five minutes. In 2004, Mount Washington had a population of about 8,500 people. Consequently, the local police department was small, with just 16 officers on staff. Buddy Stump was the department's only detective. He had only been on the job for several weeks when the call came through from the nearby McDonald's. He was the first of his colleagues to arrive at the restaurant and listened in disbelief as he was told what had happened there. The CCTV camera in the manager's office captured Laura Fletcher's entire ordeal.
大家商量了一番后，在晚上9点左右报了警。由于华盛顿山警察局只有四分之一英里远，警察在五分钟内就赶到了。2004年，华盛顿山的人口约为8500人。因此，当地警察局规模很小，只有16名警官在职。巴迪·斯图普是该局唯一的侦探。当来自附近麦当劳的电话打进来时，他才刚上任几周。他是第一位到达餐厅的同事，当他听到那里发生的事情时，简直不敢相信自己的耳朵。经理办公室里的闭路电视摄像头记录了劳拉·弗莱彻所遭受的整个折磨过程。
The footage enraged Detective Stump. He suspected the prank call was made from a payphone within sight of the McDonald's building, so that the perpetrator could watch the fallout of his sick joke. The following day, the Mount Washington police chief decided to type the words McDonald's strip search into Google. To his and Detective Stump's surprise, the search resulted in hundreds of hits. Similar phone calls had been made throughout the United States. In all of the incidents, a male caller would claim to be either a police officer or another kind of authority figure, then ask a store manager to assist with an investigation.
这段录像激怒了斯图普侦探。他怀疑恶作剧电话是打自可以看到麦当劳建筑的一个公用电话，这样肇事者就可以观看他那病态玩笑的后果。第二天，华盛顿山警察局长决定在谷歌上输入“麦当劳脱衣搜查”这几个字。令他和斯图普侦探惊讶的是，搜索结果竟然有数百条。类似的电话在全美各地都有打过。在所有事件中，一名男性来电者会自称是警官或其他类型的权威人物，然后要求商店经理协助调查。
Their requests always involved ordering a strip search be carried out on a young woman, often a teenager. Most of the calls were made to fast food restaurants, but grocery stores had also received a few. The caller appeared to be deliberately targeting small town communities. He had been active for 12 years, with his earliest calls dating back to 1992. There was a sudden spike in reports throughout the late 90s and early 2000s. The Mount Washington incident wasn't the first time he had targeted a store in Kentucky. On November 30, 2000, a female manager at a McDonald's in Litchfield received a call from a man claiming to be a police officer. He suspected one of the customers inside the restaurant was a sex offender
他们的要求总是涉及下令对一名年轻女性（通常是十几岁的小女孩）进行脱衣搜查。大多数电话都是打给快餐店的，但杂货店也接到过几个。来电者似乎在刻意针对小城镇社区。他已经活跃了12年，最早的电话可以追溯到1992年。在90年代末和2000年代初，举报数量突然激增。华盛顿山的事件并不是他第一次针对肯塔基州的一家商店。2000年11月30日，利奇菲尔德一家麦当劳的女经理接到了一名自称是警官的男子的电话。他怀疑餐厅里的其中一位顾客是一个性犯罪者
and persuaded the manager to remove her clothing in an attempt to bait the suspect into committing sexual assault. He promised that undercover officers were monitoring the situation and would rush in to protect her before an assault could actually take place. By the end of the year 2000, more than a dozen of these scam calls had been reported. When 2003 drew to a close, there had been almost 60 similar incidents. Police departments struggled to determine what actual crime had been committed or how to pursue the caller. This led to the reported phone calls often being filed under miscellaneous. As time went on, the perpetrator's demands grew increasingly aggressive. In February 2003, the perpetrator called a McDonald's in Hinesville, Georgia.
并说服经理脱掉她的衣服，企图诱使嫌疑人实施性侵犯。他承诺便衣警察正在监视局势，并会在性侵真正发生之前冲进来保护她。到2000年底，已有十多起此类诈骗电话被举报。当2003年接近尾声时，已有近60起类似事件。警察局很难确定究竟犯下了什么罪行，或者如何追查来电者。这导致被举报的电话经常被归类为杂项。随着时间的推移，肇事者的要求变得越来越具有攻击性。2003年2月，肇事者打电话给佐治亚州海因斯维尔的一家麦当劳。
Pretending to be a police officer, he commanded the restaurant manager to strip search a female employee in the women's bathroom. He then convinced her to bring in a male employee and had him carry out a cavity search on the victim. By 2004, there had been 70 of these hoaxes perpetrated across 32 American states. In February, he targeted four separate Wendy's fast food restaurants in several neighborhoods south of Boston, Massachusetts. Investigators there initially believed it was a local matter, but after looking online, they discovered the true extent of the offending. A multi-jurisdictional task force was established to investigate the crimes, led by Detective Sergeant Victor Flaherty. Just weeks before Laura Fletcher was assaulted, a 17-year-old female customer at a Taco Bell in Maricopa County, Arizona, was stripped searched by a manager while he was on the phone with the supposed police officer. Like Laura, the girl was made to perform star jumps and endure a cavity search.
他假装成一名警官，命令餐厅经理在女卫生间对一名女员工进行脱衣搜查。然后他说服她带进一名男员工，并让他对受害者进行腔内搜查。到2004年，全美32个州发生了70起此类恶作剧。2月，他将目标锁定在马萨诸塞州波士顿以南几个街区的四家不同的温蒂汉堡快餐店。那里的调查人员最初认为这是一起本地事件，但在网上搜索后，他们发现了犯罪的真正严重性。成立了一个跨辖区的特别工作组来调查这些罪行，由维克托·弗莱赫蒂警长领导。就在劳拉·弗莱彻遭到性侵几周前，亚利桑那州马里科帕县一家塔可钟的17岁女顾客被一名经理脱衣搜查，而当时该经理正与所谓的警察通话。和劳拉一样，这个女孩被迫做开合跳并忍受腔内搜查。
On this occasion, the local law enforcement was aware of the wider pattern and the task force established in Massachusetts. The Maricopa County Sheriff gave an interview on CNN, warning the public about the nationwide trend. He called it, a very dangerous situation. By the time Laura Fletcher was assaulted, at least 17 McDonald's managers had been duped by the caller. More than a dozen employees were charged with various crimes as a result, but the perpetrator remained a mystery. Those who had taken his calls described him as having a calm and authoritative manner. His conversations were peppered with police jargon, adding an element of authenticity. He often knew the names of restaurant managers or local police officers and used these to sound more credible. Some managers carried out the caller's orders with enthusiasm, but others cried while doing as they were told.
这一次，当地执法部门意识到了更广泛的模式以及在马萨诸塞州成立的工作组。马里科帕县治安官接受了CNN的采访，警告公众注意这种全国性的趋势。他称其为“一种非常危险的情况”。在劳拉·弗莱彻遭到性侵时，至少有17名麦当劳经理被来电者蒙蔽。十几名员工因此被指控犯有各种罪行，但肇事者仍然是个谜。那些接听他电话的人形容他有一种冷静而权威的语气。他的谈话中夹杂着警察的行话，增添了一丝真实感。他经常知道餐厅经理或当地警察的名字，并利用这些来听起来更可信。一些经理热情地执行来电者的命令，但其他人则在照做时哭泣。
One individual who assaulted an employee on the caller's orders later stated, I didn't want to be doing it, but it was like he was watching me. Upon learning of the scammer's extensive history, Detective Buddy Stump made it his goal to identify and capture him once and for all. After the offender had hung up on his call to the Mount Washington McDonald's, an employee had the presence of mind to dial star six nine. This function allowed a call made to a landline to be returned. The employee jotted down the scammer's number, but it was listed to a non-existent phone. Despite this, Detective Stump was able to determine that a prepaid calling card from telecommunications company AT&T was used to make the call. This discovery had also been made by other police departments, but they'd struggled to find any further information.
一名按照来电者命令侵犯员工的个人后来表示：“我不想这么做，但感觉就像他在盯着我一样。”在得知骗子的广泛历史后，巴迪·斯图普侦探将他的目标定为一劳永逸地识别并抓获他。在罪犯挂断打给华盛顿山麦当劳的电话后，一名员工机智地拨打了*69。这个功能允许回拨打到座机的电话。该员工记下了骗子的号码，但该号码登记在一个不存在的电话上。尽管如此，斯图普侦探还是能够确定，打这通电话使用的是电信公司AT&T的预付费电话卡。其他警察局也发现了这一发现，但他们很难找到任何进一步的信息。
Detective Stump was able to trace the use of the card to a payphone located outside a supermarket in Panama City, a coastal city in Florida, more than 600 miles away. After calling AT&T directly, Detective Stump learned that the largest seller of their phone cards in Panama City was Walmart, a nationwide chain of discount department stores. There were three Walmart's in Panama City. Detective Stump contacted Panama City Police, who put him in touch with Detective Victor Flaherty, the investigator leading the Massachusetts-based task force investigating the strip search scammer. Detective Flaherty had already linked the Boston scam calls to an AT&T prepaid calling card sold at a Panama City Walmart. He had even isolated the specific store where it had been purchased. However, the store only had CCTV cameras covering its entrances and exits. As there was no surveillance in place around its cash registers, there was no footage of the suspect actually buying the card.
斯图普侦探顺藤摸瓜，查到这张卡的用途指向佛罗里达州沿海城市巴拿马城一家超市外面的公用电话，距离这里600多英里远。在直接致电AT&T后，斯图普侦探得知他们在巴拿马城电话卡的最大卖家是沃尔玛，这是一家全国性的折扣百货连锁店。巴拿马城有三家沃尔玛。斯图普侦探联系了巴拿马城警方，警方将他引见给维克托·弗莱赫蒂侦探，后者是领导马萨诸塞州调查脱衣搜查诈骗犯专案组的调查员。弗莱赫蒂侦探此前已将波士顿的诈骗电话与在巴拿马城沃尔玛出售的AT&T预付费电话卡联系起来。他甚至锁定了购买该卡的特定商店。然而，该商店只有覆盖其出入口的闭路电视摄像头。由于收银台周围没有安装监控，因此没有嫌疑人实际购买该卡的录像。
Nevertheless, Detective Flaherty made a note of individuals filmed entering the store at the approximate time the card was sold. Detective Stump and Flaherty joined forces and began trying to find out when and where the calling card used in the Mount Washington case was purchased. They sourced its personal identification number and determined it had been sold at another Panama City Walmart on Friday, April 9 at 3.02pm, less than two hours before the caller initiated Laura Fletcher's assault. The card was purchased with cash, so there was no paper trail. Yet, this particular Walmart had surveillance cameras filming its registers. Footage taken at the exact time the card was sold revealed that the buyer was a white man aged between 35 and 40. He had dark, slicked back hair and eyeglasses. He wore a pair of pants with a blue stripe down the side and a black jacket with small white lettering.
尽管如此，弗莱赫蒂侦探还是记下了在售卡大约时间被拍摄到进入商店的个人。斯图普和弗莱赫蒂侦探联手，开始着手查明华盛顿山案件中使用的电话卡是什么时候、在哪里购买的。他们查到了该卡的个人识别码，并确定它是4月9日星期五下午3点02分在巴拿马城的另一家沃尔玛售出的，距离来电者发起对劳拉·弗莱彻的袭击不到两个小时。这张卡是用现金购买的，因此没有纸质记录。然而，这家特定的沃尔玛有拍摄其收银台的监控摄像头。在售卡确切时间拍摄的录像显示，购买者是一名35至40岁之间的白人男子。他留着深色、向后梳的头发，戴着眼镜。他穿着一条侧面有蓝色条纹的裤子和一件带有白色小字的黑色夹克。
Detective Flaherty recognized the man as one of the individuals he had noted entering the other Panama City Walmart at the time the calling card used in the Boston scams was bought. On June 28, Detective Flaherty arrived in Panama City to speak with local detectives. When shown the Walmart CCTV footage of the suspect, the Panama City detectives immediately recognized his clothing. It was the uniform worn by officers employed at Bay Correctional Facility, a private prison in the area. Detective Flaherty went to the prison and the warden identified the Walmart shopper as 38-year-old David Stewart. He was a guard who had worked the prison's swing shift for the past 11 months. Stewart was married with five children. He'd previously worked as a truck driver and mall security guard. He had also volunteered as an auxiliary sheriff's deputy.
弗莱赫蒂侦探认出这个人是他在波士顿诈骗案所用电话卡购买时记录的进入另一家巴拿马城沃尔玛的个人之一。6月28日，弗莱赫蒂侦探抵达巴拿马城与当地侦探交谈。当看到嫌疑人的沃尔玛监控录像时，巴拿马城的侦探们立即认出了他的衣服。那是该地区一家私立监狱贝湾惩教设施雇用的警官所穿的制服。弗莱赫蒂侦探去了监狱，监狱长认出这位沃尔玛购物者是38岁的大卫·斯图尔特。他是一名狱警，在过去的11个月里一直上监狱的轮换班。斯图尔特已婚，有五个孩子。他以前当过卡车司机和商场保安。他还曾作为辅助副警长做过志愿者。
Detective Flaherty paid Stewart a visit and after introducing himself, asked, Why would a sergeant from Massachusetts be coming down here to talk to you? Stewart replied that he had no idea. Detective Flaherty then queried whether he had ever owned a calling card. At that moment, it appeared to Detective Flaherty that Stewart began shaking and sweating profusely. He unclipped the tie he was wearing and asked whether anyone had been hurt. Detective Flaherty said that no one had been physically harmed, but he was sure there would be ongoing mental traumas. Stewart then remarked,
弗莱赫蒂侦探拜访了斯图尔特，在自我介绍后问道：“为什么马萨诸塞州的一个警长会来这里找你？”斯图尔特回答说他不知道。弗莱赫蒂侦探随后追问他是否拥有过电话卡。就在那一刻，弗莱赫蒂侦探看到斯图尔特开始浑身发抖并大量出汗。他解开了佩戴的领带，问是否有人受伤。弗莱赫蒂侦探说没有人受到身体伤害，但他确信会有持续的心理创伤。然后斯图尔特评论道，
Amen. It's over. Despite his cryptic remark expressing relief that it was all over, David Stewart claimed to know nothing about the scam calls and denied ever owning a calling card. He then promptly retained a lawyer and reserved the right to remain silent. Massachusetts investigators were unsure what to even charge him with and Panama City police were unfamiliar with the calls he was accused of making. 20 miles north of Panama City, officers pulled into the dirt road that led to Stewart's mobile home. They had been issued a warrant to search the premises. Inside the trailer, they found multiple guns and holsters.
“阿门。一切都结束了。”尽管大卫·斯图尔特发表了含糊不清的评论，表示这一切都结束了，但他声称对诈骗电话一无所知，并否认自己拥有一张电话卡。随后他立即请了律师，并保留了保持沉默的权利。马萨诸塞州的调查人员甚至不确定该以什么罪名起诉他，巴拿马城警方对被指控拨打的电话也很陌生。在巴拿马城以北20英里处，警察将车开进通往斯图尔特移动房屋的土路。他们已经获得了搜查该住所的搜查令。在拖车内，他们发现了多支枪支和枪套。
Hundreds of law enforcement magazines were scattered about. There were also dozens of applications for jobs at police departments. A single prepaid calling card was recovered. It wasn't the one used to call the Mount Washington McDonald's, but it was connected to nine other scam calls made during the summer of 2003. The targets in those calls included Wendy's and Burger King restaurants in Idaho and Oklahoma. The first of David Stewart's charges was handed down by Mount Washington police. They charged him with soliciting for sodomy, which was a felony crime. He was placed under arrest and extradited to Kentucky.
到处散落着数百本执法杂志。还有几十份警察局的工作申请表。搜出了一张预付费电话卡。它不是打给华盛顿山麦当劳的那张，但它与2003年夏天拨打的其他九起诈骗电话有关。这些电话的目标包括爱达荷州和俄克拉荷马州的温蒂汉堡和汉堡王餐厅。华盛顿山警方对大卫·斯图尔特提出了第一项指控。他们指控他教唆鸡奸，这是一项重罪。他被逮捕并引渡到肯塔基州。
He was also charged with impersonating a police officer, as well as the misdemeanors of soliciting sexual abuse and unlawful imprisonment. Stewart pleaded not guilty and was released on bail for $100,000. His trial was slated to take place at the end of the year. The other individuals involved in Laura Fletcher's assault were facing ramifications of their own. Walter Nix was charged with sodomy and assault. He maintained that he too was a victim, as he genuinely believed he was following the orders of a police officer, even when those orders turned violent and sexual. His fiance, Donna Summers, had been shown the CCTV footage of Nix sexually assaulting Laura and promptly ended their relationship. Summers was initially suspended from her assistant manager position at McDonald's and later fired.
他还被控冒充警察，以及教唆性虐待和非法拘禁的轻罪。斯图尔特不认罪，并以10万美元保释。他的审判预定在年底进行。卷入劳拉·弗莱彻袭击案的其他个人也面临着各自的后果。沃尔特·尼克斯被控鸡奸罪和 assault 罪。他坚称自己也是受害者，因为他真心相信自己是在遵从警官的命令，即使这些命令变得暴力和色情。他的未婚妻唐娜·萨默斯被观看了尼克斯性侵劳拉的闭路电视录像后，立即结束了他们的关系。萨默斯最初被暂停了麦当劳助理经理的职务，后来被解雇。
In dismissing her, McDonald's cited violation of company policy, specifically bringing a non-employee behind the store's counters. Summers was also charged with one misdemeanor count of unlawful imprisonment. The other assistant manager on duty that night, Kim Dockery, was transferred to another restaurant. Laura Fletcher never returned to her job at McDonald's. The ordeal left her suffering from panic attacks, insomnia, anxiety, and depression, and she was terrorized by nightmares of a man attacking her. Laura did graduate high school the month after her attack, but was too traumatized to enroll at the University of Louisville as she had planned. In a court document filed that year, she stated, I can't trust anyone. I push people out of my life because I don't want them to know what happened.
麦当劳在解雇她时列举了她违反公司政策的行为，具体是将非员工带到店内的柜台后面。萨默斯还被控一项非法拘禁轻罪。当晚在值的另一位助理经理金·多克里被调到了另一家餐厅。劳拉·弗莱彻再也没有回到麦当劳的工作岗位。这场折磨让她患上了恐慌发作、失眠、焦虑和抑郁，并且经常梦见一个男人袭击她的噩梦而感到恐怖。劳拉确实在袭击发生后的次月从高中毕业，但由于遭受严重心理创伤而无法像计划的那样入读路易斯维尔大学。在那一年提交的一份法庭文件中，她写道：“我不信任任何人。我把人们推开，因为我不想让他们知道发生了什么。”
Laura Fletcher filed a civil lawsuit against McDonald's, alleging that they had failed to warn employees of the strip search scammer who was targeting fast food outlets. In response, McDonald's stated in court documents that Laura herself was partially to blame for her assault. They asserted that she should have realized that the caller was not a real police officer. The company's reaction upset Laura and played a part in her approving a plea bargain for Walter Nix. She wanted an apology and for her name to be absolved. His charges of sodomy and assault together carried a maximum of 20 years in prison. They were negotiated down to one count of unlawful imprisonment and one of sexual misconduct. Nix had agreed to say sorry to Laura in court and explained that she wasn't to blame.
劳拉·弗莱彻对麦当劳提起了一起民事诉讼，指控他们未能警告员工注意针对快餐店的脱衣搜查诈骗犯。作为回应，麦当劳在法庭文件中表示，劳拉本人应对她的袭击承担部分责任。他们断言她本应该意识到打电话的人不是真正的警察。该公司的反应让劳拉感到不安，并在她同意与沃尔特·尼克斯进行认罪协商中起到了一定作用。她想要一个道歉，并为自己的名字正名。他的鸡奸和 assault 指控最高可判处20年监禁。经过协商，这些指控被减为一项非法拘禁罪和一项性行为不端罪。尼克斯同意在法庭上向劳拉道歉，并解释说她没有错。
In October 2005, it was announced that Nix would only receive probation despite previously agreeing to a one-year term. The prosecuting attorney said that he agreed to probation because Nix didn't have a criminal history and his story of being duped by an experienced hoaxer would likely be compelling to a jury. He did note, however, that it was troubling that somebody could believe performing a sexual act would form part of any criminal investigation. Quote, there had to be a point where he realized that this wasn't right. Nix entered an outfit plea which allowed him to maintain his innocence while acknowledging that there was enough evidence to convict him. When Laura discovered that this deal allowed Nix to technically deny any wrongdoing and would prevent him from having to register as a sex offender, she felt betrayed yet again. Her lawyer explained that her opposition stemmed from Nix's claim that he'd merely been following orders. Quote, that is the defence made by Germans at Nuremberg. You could be fooled into some of the things he did, but not sodomy.
2005年10月，宣布尼克斯尽管先前同意了一年的刑期，但只会获得缓刑。检察官表示，他同意缓刑是因为尼克斯没有犯罪记录，而且他被一个经验丰富的恶作剧者愚弄的说法很可能会对陪审团产生说服力。然而，他确实指出，令人不安的是，有人会认为进行性行为会构成任何刑事犯罪调查的一部分。“一定有一个时刻，他意识到这不是对的。”尼克斯提出了阿尔福德抗辩，这使他能够在承认有足够证据定罪的同时保持自己的清白。当劳拉发现这笔交易允许尼克斯从技术上否认任何不当行为，并将阻止他作为性犯罪者进行登记时，她再次感到被背叛了。她的律师解释说，她的反对源于尼克斯声称他只是在奉命行事。“那是德国人在纽伦堡的辩护。你可能会被他所做的一些事情所愚弄，但鸡奸绝不可能。”
On November 2, 2005, Nix's lawyer argued in court that his outfit plea be allowed to stand. She pointed to her client's remorse and his below-average IQ of 83, stating, He does feel terribly ashamed. He has hurt his family and himself and Laura. Nix offered a public apology to Laura, saying, I had no intention of hurting anyone. Nevertheless, Judge Tom Waller rejected the plea agreement. He had viewed the surveillance footage of the attack and was deeply troubled by what had occurred. He set a trial date for the following month. At around the same time that Nix's court proceedings were being negotiated, Laura agreed to speak to the ABC news program Primetime about her ordeal.
2005年11月2日，尼克斯的律师在法庭上辩称应该允许其阿尔福德抗辩成立。她指出她的当事人有悔意，且IQ低于平均水平为83，并说道：“他感到非常羞愧。他伤害了他的家人、自己和劳拉。”尼克斯向劳拉公开道歉，说道：“我无意伤害任何人。然而，汤姆·沃勒法官拒绝了认罪协议。他观看了袭击的监控录像，对发生的事情深感不安。他将审判日期定在下个月。大约在尼克斯的法庭诉讼正在协商的同时，劳拉同意向ABC新闻节目《黄金时间》讲述她的遭遇。
She explained how she had trusted Donna Summers, believing her role as assistant manager meant she would take care of her staff. Laura teared up as she described how she had felt during the strip search, stating, I was scared. I didn't know what to think. I didn't know what to do. I was petrified. She said that she had desperately wanted to escape the office, but couldn't bear the added humiliation of running naked through the busy restaurant. Laura's parents had raised her to do as she was told without arguing, and she said this made it difficult for her to refuse the orders of an older adult. The show included comments from a clinical psychologist who confirmed that Laura's description of feeling as though she had left her own body during the assault was common among survivors of sexual abuse. Donna Summers also agreed to participate in the program. Like her fiance, Summers was adamant that she had believed the individual on the phone was a police officer.
她解释了自己当初是如何信任唐娜·萨默斯（Donna Summers），因为她相信对方身为副经理，意味着会照顾好手下的员工。劳拉在描述自己在搜身时的感受时流下了眼泪，她说：“我很害怕。我不知道该想什么。我不知道该做什么。我吓呆了。”她说自己当时非常渴望逃离办公室，但又无法承受在人头攒动的餐厅里赤身裸体奔跑所带来的双重羞辱。劳拉的父母从小教育她要听从吩咐、不要争辩，她说这使得她在拒绝一个成年长辈的命令时感到十分困难。节目中引用了一位临床心理学家的评论，该心理学家证实，劳拉在描述袭击发生时感觉自己仿佛灵魂出窍的这种感受，在性虐待幸存者中非常普遍。唐娜·萨默斯也同意参与这期节目的录制。和她的未婚夫一样，萨默斯坚信她当时真的以为电话那头的人是一名警察。
Throughout the interview, Summers' version of events directly contradicted the CCTV footage shown of the attack. She said Laura had not cried or begged for the strip search to stop, but the video evidence showed her openly sobbing and pleading with her managers. When asked why she left a naked teenager alone with her fiance, Summers repeatedly stated that Laura had always been covered up. Yet, the interviewer pointed out that the apron given to Laura was small and only partially concealed the front of her body. Summers denied ever seeing Laura without her apron while Nix was supervising her. The interviewer attempted to show Summers a portion of the surveillance video that showed her entering the office while Laura was completely naked. Summers' lawyer interrupted from off-camera to prevent her client from offering an explanation. Walter Nix's trial date was delayed so that he could undergo a mental health evaluation.
在整个采访过程中，萨默斯对事件经过的说法与案发现场闭路电视监控录画的内容直接矛盾。她声称劳拉当时没有哭，也没有哀求停止搜身，但视频证据显示劳拉当时公开痛哭，并恳求她的经理们放过她。当被问及为何将一个赤身裸体的十几岁女孩单独留在她未婚夫身边时，萨默斯反复坚称劳拉一直都遮盖着身体。然而，采访者指出，发给劳拉的围裙很小，只能勉强遮住身体的前面。萨默斯否认在尼克斯（Nicks）监督劳拉期间曾见过她没穿围裙的样子。采访者试图向萨默斯展示监控视频的一部分，该片段显示她在劳拉赤身裸体时进入了办公室。萨默斯的律师在镜头外打断了谈话，以防止其当事人作出解释。沃尔特·尼克斯（Walter Nix）的审判日期被推迟，以便他能够接受心理健康评估。
Eventually, his lawyers negotiated another plea deal. In February 2006, Nix pleaded guilty to charges of sexual abuse, sexual misconduct and unlawful imprisonment in exchange for a five-year prison sentence. When asked if she agreed to the deal, Laura confirmed that she did. This new arrangement required Nix to serve time, register as a sex offender and testify as a witness at the pending trial of the alleged scammer, David Stewart. Three weeks later, Donna Summers entered an offered plea to her misdemeanor charge of unlawful imprisonment. She had initially intended to plead not guilty, but an agreement was struck to prevent Laura from having to testify. Summers was sentenced to one year's probation. The prosecutor had argued in favor of Summers being sent to prison, stating,
最终，他的律师通过谈判达成了另一项认罪协议。2006年2月，尼克斯对性虐待、性骚扰和非法监禁的指控表示认罪，以此换取五年的监禁判决。当被问及是否同意这项协议时，劳拉确认她确实同意。这一新安排要求尼克斯服刑、登记为性犯罪者，并作为证人出庭指控涉嫌诈骗的嫌疑人大卫·斯图尔特（David Stewart）。三 weeks后，唐娜·萨默斯对她受到的非法监禁轻罪指控进行了认罪答辩。她最初打算做无罪辩护，但为了避免劳拉出庭作证，双方最终达成了一项协议。萨默斯被判处一年缓刑。检察官曾辩护支持判处萨默斯监禁，并表示：
It didn't matter whether Summers thought she was dealing with police or not. If the president of the United States said to take that child's clothes away and detain her in that room, there was no excuse for it. However, leniency was granted after Laura said that she believed her former manager had been genuinely duped and was another victim of the crime. Summers left the courthouse in tears. She told the media that she never would have detained and stripped Laura if McDonald's had warned her about the other scam phone calls. David Stewart's trial commenced on October 24, 2006, at the Bullitt County Circuit Court. It had been two and a half years since Laura Fletcher's assault. The delaying court proceedings was to allow for the charges against Nicks and Summers to be addressed first, so they could appear as witnesses against Stewart.
萨默斯以为自己是在和警察打交道还是别的什么并不重要。如果美利坚合众国总统下令脱掉那个孩子的衣服并将她扣留在那个房间里，这也绝对没有任何借口。不过，在劳拉表示她相信自己的前经理是真的被愚弄、也是该罪行的另一名受害者之后，法院给予了宽大处理。萨默斯流着泪离开了法院。她告诉媒体，如果麦当劳曾就其他诈骗电话向她发出过警告，她绝不会拘禁和搜查劳拉。大卫·斯图尔特的审判于2006年10月24日在布利特县巡回法院开始。距离劳拉·弗莱彻遭受袭击已经过去两年半了。推迟法庭诉讼程序是为了首先处理针对尼克斯和萨默斯的指控，以便他们能够出庭指控斯图尔特。
In their opening address, the prosecution warned the jury that they would be hearing testimony so bizarre that it would be difficult to believe. Yet, the court was assured that phone records and surveillance video would prove the defendant's guilt. Stewart's attorney insisted that the allegations were false and there was no evidence to support them. He claimed that police had only charged his client because they were desperate to make an arrest. Walter Nicks took the stand and told the court that within minutes of speaking to the individual calling himself Officer Scott, he felt as though the man had control of his mind. Nicks described himself as easygoing and amenable to following authority figures. He discussed the tasks that Officer Scott wanted Laura to perform and explained how he had conveyed them on the officer's behalf. Under cross-examination by Stewart's attorney, Nicks was asked whether he had eventually realized that the things he was doing had nothing to do with a police investigation.
在开案陈词中，检方警告陪审团，他们接下来听到的证词将会诡异到难以置信的程度。然而，法庭确信通话记录和监控视频将证明被告有罪。斯图尔特的律师坚称这些指控是虚假的，并且没有任何证据支持它们。他声称警方之所以起诉他的当事人，纯粹是因为他们急于破案。沃尔特·尼克斯走上证人席，对法庭说，在与自称斯科特警官的人通话几分钟内，他就觉得这个人控制了他的大脑。尼克斯将自己描述为性格随和、容易听从权威人物指挥的人。他谈到了斯科特警官希望劳拉履行的任务，并解释了他如何代表警官传达这些任务。在斯图尔特律师的交叉盘问下，尼克斯被问及他是否最终意识到自己所做的事情与警方调查毫无关系。
Nicks insisted that he had simply done as instructed and described the caller as a smooth talker. Donna Summers also testified. She claimed she had spoken to three separate people on the phone with the main individual being Officer Scott. In the background, she heard the static of police radios. Summers said that Officer Scott had known the names of several of her employees as well as the name of a customer in the restaurant. He'd claimed that he had the store's manager, Lisa Siddons, on another line. Summers even thought she'd heard Lisa's voice in the background during the call. Under cross-examination, Summers was asked whether she thought the call could have been made from an outdoor pay phone as the prosecution was alleging. She said that wasn't possible.
尼克斯坚称他只是照着指示行事，并形容打电话的人是个花言巧语的家伙。唐娜·萨默斯也出庭作证。她声称自己曾与电话里的三个人分别交谈过，其中主要的人是斯科特警官。在背景音中，她听到了警用无线电的杂音。萨默斯说，斯科特警官不仅知道她几名员工的名字，还知道餐厅里一名顾客的名字。他声称店里的经理丽莎·西登斯（Lisa Siddons）正在另一条线路上。萨默斯甚至认为她在通话期间隐约听到了丽莎的声音。在交叉盘问中，萨默斯被问及她是否认为这通电话可能是像检方所称的那样从室外公用电话打来的。她说这是不可能的。
Mount Washington investigator Detective Buddy Stump was asked how the scammer could have known employee and customer names or presented himself as three separate individuals. He replied that he didn't know, as investigators were never able to verify those assertions. Laura Fletcher, who was now 20 years old, testified on the second day of the trial. Summers had claimed that she gave Laura the choice to be searched at the restaurant or be taken into police custody and that Laura had opted to stay at McDonald's. Laura refuted this, saying that she had begged to be taken to the police station in the hopes that the matter could be sorted out there. When the prosecutor asked why she never tried to leave the office, Laura explained that she felt she couldn't as she was naked and feared nicks might hurt her. Moreover, she depended on the job to support her family and was terrified of losing it. As her father was an Air Force veteran, she had been raised to respect and obey her elders and authority figures.
山华盛顿镇的调查员巴迪·斯图姆（Buddy Stump）侦探被问及诈骗者怎么会知道员工和顾客的名字，或者将自己伪装成三个人。他回答说他不知道，因为调查人员始终无法核实这些说法。劳拉·弗莱彻当时已经20岁了，她在审判的第二天出庭作证。萨默斯曾声称她给了劳拉选择，是在餐厅接受搜身还是被警方带走拘留，而劳拉选择留在麦当劳。劳拉反驳了这一点，称她曾恳求被带到警察局，希望能在那里解决问题。当检察官问她为什么从不试图离开办公室时，劳拉解释说她觉得自己无法离开，因为她当时赤身裸体，并害怕尼克斯可能会伤害她。此外，她还要靠这份工作养家糊口，极度害怕失去它。由于她的父亲是一名空军退伍军人，她从小就被教育要尊重和服从长辈以及权威人士。
Laura said she had pleaded for Summers to help her on multiple occasions, but was ignored. While relating details of her ordeal to the court, Laura noted there were gaps in her memory as she had, quote, blanked out some aspects of the assault. Detective Victor Flaherty told the court that Stewart had made the cryptic remark, Amen, it's over, during their initial conversation. Stewart's attorney insisted that the comment was made at the end of an interrogation and was an expression of relief that it was over. The defense attempted to cast doubt by pointing out that no one had seen Stewart at the payphone where the three-hour call to the Mount Washington McDonald's was made from. They also pointed out that although a prepaid calling card linked to several scam calls was found in Stewart's home, it was not the one used to contact the Mount Washington McDonald's. Thomas Sims, the maintenance worker who had put a stop to Laura's ordeal, testified that Laura had stated she was going to get a big check as a result of what she had been through. Thomas admitted that he'd never told the police about this remark and only repeated it to McDonald's corporate officials who had interviewed him later on.
劳拉说她曾多次恳求萨默斯帮帮她，但都被无视了。在向法庭讲述自己的悲惨经历时，劳拉指出她的记忆中存在空白，因为她“在某种程度上把袭击的一些细节给选择性失忆了”。维克托·弗兰赫蒂（Victor Flaherty）侦探告诉法庭，斯图尔特在最初的谈话中曾说过一句神秘的话：“阿门，结束了。”斯图尔特的律师坚称，这句话是在审讯结束时说的，表达的是一切终于结束的解脱感。辩方试图通过指出没有人看到斯图尔特在那个给山华盛顿麦当劳打了长达三个小时电话的公用电话亭旁来制造疑窦。他们还指出，虽然在斯图尔特家中找到了一张与多起诈骗电话有关的预付费电话卡，但这并不是用来联系山华盛顿麦当劳的那张。托马斯·西姆斯（Thomas Sims）是阻止劳拉遭遇折磨的维修工，他作证说劳拉曾说过她将因为自己的遭遇而获得一张巨额支票。托马斯承认他从未将这句话告诉过警察，只是向后来采访他的麦当劳公司官员提过。
Stewart's legal team used this testimony to theorize that Laura had orchestrated the attack as a scam to obtain a large sum of money. Laura's attorney told the media that the accusation that her client was involved in her own assault was, quote, a ridiculous and desperate suggestion. In his closing argument, Stewart's lawyer told the jury that his client was nothing more than a fall guy for police, stating, They came to a conclusion, then went about looking for facts to support it. On Tuesday, October 31, the jury of six men and six women retired to consider their verdict. They returned to court less than two hours later. David Stewart closed his eyes and bowed his head as a not guilty verdict was read aloud. The jury had acquitted him of all charges.
斯图尔特的法律团队利用这一证词推论说，劳拉策划了这次袭击，是一场企图骗取巨额金钱的骗局。劳拉的律师向媒体表示，指控她的当事人参与了自己的遇袭是一项“荒谬且绝望的猜测”。在结案陈词中，斯图尔特的律师对陪审团说，他的当事人不过是替警方背锅的牺牲品，并宣称：“他们先得出一个结论，然后到处寻找支持该结论的事实。”10月31日星期二，由六名男性和六名女性组成的陪审团退庭商议他们的裁决。不到两个小时后，他们返回法庭。当宣读无罪判决时，大卫·斯图尔特闭上眼睛，低下了头。陪审团判定他所有指控不成立。
When he was permitted to leave the courtroom, Stewart left in silence with his family. He refused to speak with the waiting press. Stewart's attorney celebrated the acquittal and told journalists it was the result of what evidence the prosecution had. But prosecutor Mike Mann said he was certain police had found the right person. He pointed out that there had been no further strip search scam calls since Stewart was arrested two and a half years earlier. Law enforcement agencies in other jurisdictions across the country had been waiting to see how the trial against Stewart panned out. For many of the scam calls that occurred prior to Laura Fletcher's assault, the only crime Stewart could have been charged with was a misdemeanor. Extradition from another state would not have been permitted under these circumstances.
当他被允许离开法庭时，斯图尔特和他的家人默默地离开了。他拒绝与等候在外的记者交谈。斯图尔特的律师为无罪释放进行庆祝，并告诉记者这是检方证据不足的结果。但检察官迈克·曼恩（Mike Mann）表示，他确信警方找到了正确的人。他指出，自从两年半前斯图尔特被捕以来，就再也没有发生过针对此类搜身诈骗的电话。全国其他司法管辖区的执法机构一直都在观望针对斯图尔特的审判结果会如何。对于在劳拉·弗莱彻遇袭之前发生的许多诈骗电话，斯图尔特唯一能被起诉的罪名只是轻罪。在这种情况下，不允许从其他州进行引渡。
After the jury in Bullock County, Kentucky found Stewart not guilty, there were no further charges brought against him for any of the other cases throughout the United States, of which there were more than 70. Laura Fletcher was seeking more than $200 million in damages from McDonald's. She was suing the then $59 billion corporation for assault, battery, sexual harassment, and failure to train. Her attorneys alleged that McDonald's failed to protect Laura by neglecting to warn staff about the ongoing hoaxes. The company had been aware of the issue for at least two years prior to her ordeal. There had been about 30 other scam calls to McDonald's restaurants throughout the country that involved girls and young women being assaulted and forced to strip in front of others. 12 of these incidents resulted in the corporation being taken to court in four different states. Settlements had been reached in all of these cases.
在肯塔基州布利特县的陪审团裁定斯图尔特无罪后，美国各地发生的所有其他类似案件（共有70多起）再也没有对其实施任何进一步的指控。劳拉·弗莱彻正向麦当劳寻求超过2亿美元的赔偿。她起诉这家当时价值590亿美元的公司存在故意伤害、殴打、性骚扰以及未能履行培训职责。她的律师指控麦当劳未能通过警告员工注意正在发生的骗局来保护劳拉。该公司在她的苦难发生前至少两年就已经意识到了这个问题。全美各地曾发生过大约30起针对麦当劳餐厅的类似诈骗电话，涉及女孩和年轻女性遭到袭击并被迫在他人面前脱衣。其中12起事件导致该公司在四个不同的州被推上法庭。所有这些案件均已达成和解。
Laura's was the first to proceed the trial. In addition to suing McDonald's, Laura's suit named assistant managers Donna Summers and Kim Dockery as well as David Stewart. Stewart responded with a letter that read in part, I received your notice but I'm in no way responsible. I feel bad for your loss because I am a victim as well. I lost my job, my home, and my car all over something I did not do. Louisville newspaper The Courier Journal revealed that Florida property records indicated Stewart had not lost the trailer where he resided, but he had deeded it to his wife for $100.
劳拉的案子是第一个进入审判程序的。除了起诉麦当劳外，劳拉的诉讼还点名了副经理唐娜·萨默斯、金·多克里（Kim Dockery）以及大卫·斯图尔特。斯图尔特回信写道：“我收到了你的通知，但我绝不负任何责任。我为你的损失感到难过，因为我也是受害者。我失去了工作、我的家和我的车，这一切都是因为一件我根本没做过的事。”路易斯维尔报纸《信使报》（The Courier Journal）披露，佛罗里达州的财产记录显示，斯图尔特并没有失去他居住的拖车房，而是以100美元的价格把它过户给了他的妻子。
Donna Summers filed a cross complaint against McDonald's for $50 million. She claimed that they had failed to warn store managers about the hoaxer. Her case would be presented alongside Laura's. In response, McDonald's asserted that Laura was the victim of a malicious hoax by individuals not representing McDonald's. They blamed Summers and Walter Nix for the incident as well as Laura herself. McDonald's insisted that all three should have realized the call was a scam. They also stated that strip searches had been against company policy since 2001 and Summers should have known this as it was mentioned in the store manual. After a lengthy discovery period in which 57 depositions were obtained from more than 40 witnesses, the trial commenced in the Bullitt County Circuit Court on September 10, 2007.
唐娜·萨默斯对麦当劳提起了5000万美元的反诉。她声称麦当劳未能警告店长注意骗局。她的案子将与劳拉的案子合并审理。作为回应，麦当劳坚称劳拉是由不代表麦当劳的个人所策划的恶毒骗局的受害者。他们将这起事件归咎于萨默斯、沃尔特·尼克斯以及劳拉本人。麦当劳坚称，这三个人本都应该意识到这通电话是个骗局。他们还表示，自2001年以来，搜身检查就一直是公司政策所禁止的，萨默斯理应知道这一点，因为门店手册中已经提到了这一点。在经过漫长的证据开示期（从40多名证人那里获得了57份证词）之后，该案于2007年9月10日在布利特县巡回法院正式开庭审理。
McDonald's had withheld 16 boxes of evidence regarding prior hoaxes from the plaintiffs on the grounds that handing them over would violate attorney-client privilege. A judge forced them to surrender the material the evening before the trial began. The case had received national attention and consequently, it was difficult to find jurors who were unfamiliar with it. Out of 110 potential jurors, less than a dozen had never heard of the case before. Eventually, the pool was narrowed down to 15, including three alternates. The first witness for the plaintiffs was McDonald's US security manager who testified via video link about the other scam calls the company received between 1994 and 2004. He said that the company realized there was a problem in 2001 after franchises began reporting the incident. A top attorney for McDonald's conceded that the warning about the calls was inadequate.
麦当劳以交出这些材料会违反律师与客户的特权为由，向原告隐瞒了16箱关于以往骗局的证据。法官在审判开始的前一天晚上强迫他们交出了这些材料。该案件受到了全国范围的关注，因此很难找到对它完全不了解的陪审员。在110名潜在陪审员中，只有不到十几人以前从未听说过这个案子。最终，陪审团名单缩小到15人，其中包括3名候补陪审员。原告的第一位证人是麦当劳美国安全经理，他通过视频连线作证，讲述了该公司在1994年至2004年期间收到的其他诈骗电话。他说，在各个加盟店开始报告此类事件后，公司在2001年意识到了问题的存在。麦当劳的一位高级律师承认，针对这些电话的警告是不够充分的。
They said employees weren't told about the scam calls because the corporation didn't want to discourage them from cooperating with the genuine law enforcement officers. Expert witness Barry Collins, who was a social psychologist from the University of California, told the court that all of the calls were likely made by a single perpetrator as they all shared an identical method and signature. He said that the perpetrator was someone who, quote, enjoyed being in control and ruining people's lives and derived some sexual pleasure from his exploits. Professor Collins explained that managers who fell for the scam calls were won over gradually. The caller would dish out compliments and commendation to encourage the managers and assure them that they were doing the right thing. His trivial requests slowly escalated to more outrageous demands. Collins testified that if McDonald's had been serious about putting a stop to the incidents, then they could have done so as they had intensive training programs set up on a range of other matters. A psychiatrist who had examined Laura testified that she would suffer post-traumatic stress disorder for the rest of her life.
他们说，之所以不把诈骗电话的情况告诉员工，是因为公司不想打消他们配合真正执法人员工作的积极性。来自加利福尼亚大学的社会心理学家、专家证人巴里·柯林斯（Barry Collins）向法庭表示，所有这些电话很可能都是由同一个作案人打的，因为它们都具有完全相同的作案手法和特征。他说，作案者是一个“喜欢掌控一切、毁掉别人生活，并从中获得某种性快感”的人。柯林斯教授解释说，那些落入骗局陷阱的经理是一点点被说服的。打电话的人会抛出恭维和表扬，以鼓励经理并向他们保证他们正在做正确的事情。他那些微不足道的请求慢慢升级为更加离谱的要求。柯林斯作证说，如果麦当劳真的认真想要制止这些事件，他们完全可以做到，因为他们在其他一系列问题上已经建立了一套密集的培训项目。曾为劳拉做过检查的精神病医生作证说，她在余生中都将遭受创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的折磨。
She was also fearful of strangers and struggled with intimacy. On Thursday, September 20, Laura Fletcher began what would end up being six hours of testimony. She broke down in tears as she discussed the assault and its long-standing impact on her, including her struggle to conceal her pain, shame and humiliation from friends and family. When asked where she thought responsibility for the incident lay, she replied, McDonald's. When it was time for Donna Summers to take the stand, she wept and admitted that she had considered taking her own life due to ongoing feelings of guilt. Summers said she prayed for Laura daily, but acknowledged that she hadn't asked enough questions when the scammer called. She insisted that McDonald's had never trained her on the matter, or made it clear that strip searches were a violation of company policy. When asked why she left her fiance alone with a naked teenager, Summers said she had believed Nix was kind and gentle, and said she would have trusted him with her own daughter.
她还对陌生人感到恐惧，并且在亲密关系上苦苦挣扎。9月20日星期四，劳拉·弗莱彻开始作证，最终这证词持续了足足六个小时。在谈到袭击事件及其对她造成的长期影响时，她失声痛哭，包括她极力向朋友和家人隐瞒痛苦、羞耻和屈辱的挣扎。当被问及她认为这起事件的责任在谁时，她回答道：“麦当劳。”轮到唐娜·萨默斯走上证人席时，她哭着承认，由于内心的负罪感挥之不去，她曾考虑过自杀。萨默斯说她每天都为劳拉祈祷，但也承认骗子打电话来时她没有问足够多的问题。她坚称麦当劳从未就此事对她进行过培训，也没有明确表示搜身检查违反了公司政策。当被问及为什么把未婚夫单独和一个赤身裸体的十几岁女孩留在房间里时，萨默斯说她当时相信尼克斯是个善良温柔的人，并表示她甚至敢把自己的亲生女儿托付给他。
In their opening statement, McDonald's blamed Donna Summers for the assault by saying that if she hadn't violated company policy by bringing Nix into the manager's office, then it wouldn't have happened. The company denied the assertion that they had not sufficiently warned staff about the scammer. A few days before Laura's assault on April 9, 2004, a voice message about the calls was sent to McDonald's managers all over the country. One of the company's human resources executives testified that Donna Summers exercised poor judgment over a long period of time, and noted that she didn't have authority to remove Laura's clothing, or invite a non-employee to the back of the restaurant. A psychiatrist and psychologist who were paid as expert witnesses by McDonald's contradicted the plaintiff's psychiatrist by saying that Laura's trauma was not permanent. One even suggested that she had grown stronger as a result of her assault. The defense also argued that Laura now had a happy life with a long-term boyfriend and a well-paid job at a legal firm. Lisa Siddons, the Mount Washington McDonald's manager, appeared on behalf of the defense.
在开案陈词中，麦当劳将袭击归咎于唐娜·萨默斯，称如果她不是把尼克斯带进经理办公室从而违反了公司政策，这一切就不会发生。该公司否认了他们没有充分警告员工注意骗子的说法。在2004年4月9日劳拉遭遇袭击几天前，一条关于这些电话的语音消息被发送给了全国各地的麦当劳经理。该公司的一位人力资源高管作证说，唐娜·萨默斯在很长一段时间里做出了糟糕的判断，并指出她既没有权力脱掉劳拉的衣服，也没有权力邀请非员工进入餐厅后台。麦当劳花钱聘请的精神病医生和心理学家作为专家证人，与原告的精神病医生唱反调，称劳拉的创伤并非永久性的。其中一人甚至暗示，她在遭遇袭击后变得更坚强了。辩方还辩称，劳拉现在与一个长期交往的男友过着幸福的生活，并在一家律师事务所拥有高薪工作。山华盛顿麦当劳的经理丽莎·西登斯作为辩方证人出庭。
She said she had received the company's voicemail about the scammer, but hadn't passed it on to her assistant managers because she didn't think it was important. She also added, quote, Anyone dumb enough to fall for it shouldn't be a manager at McDonald's. On cross-examination, Lisa accepted that the voicemail had been vague. It merely referred to a caller asking for employees to be detained, and to mention nothing about strip searches. When asked if she would have treated the voicemail more seriously, had she known what sorts of abuses the caller was demanding, Lisa answered yes, and burst into tears. Lisa had worked for McDonald's since 1981, but said she was unfamiliar with its policy barring strip searches, and consequently couldn't have told her subordinates about it. It emerged that the company had never trained anybody on the policy. It was one of many listed in a 1000-page manual.
她说她收到了公司关于骗子的语音留言，但没有将其转告给她的副经理，因为她认为这不重要。她还补充说：“任何笨到会相信这种把戏的人都不配当麦当劳的经理。”在交叉盘问中，丽莎承认那条语音留言确实很含糊。它只是提及一个来电者要求拘留员工，完全没有提到搜身。当被问及如果她知道来电者要求的是何种虐待行为，她是否会对该语音留言采取更严肃的态度时，丽莎回答说会，并当场失声痛哭。丽莎自1981年起就在麦当劳工作，但她说她并不熟悉禁止搜身的政策，因此不可能将此事告知下属。事实证明，公司从未就这项政策对任何人进行过培训。它只是写在一本长达1000页的手册里的众多条目之一。
The trial concluded after four weeks. The jury of eight women and four men were given 31 pages of instructions and 12 possible verdicts to consider. After deliberating for 13 hours, the jury found in favour of Laura's suit. They assigned half of the blame for her assault to the scammer and the other half to McDonald's. Laura was awarded a total of $6.1 million. This included $1.1 million in compensatory damages and $5 million in punitive damages. The jury attached a note to their verdict imploring McDonald's to offer more employee training on sexual harassment and scam calls. It was later revealed that the jury had taken so long deliberating because they had been unable to agree on how much money Laura should receive. One juror wanted to award her $100 million, while another wanted to give her just $1. The jury also awarded $1.1 million to Donna Summers.
审判在四周后结束。由八名女性和四名男性组成的陪审团收到了31页的指示和12种可能的裁决供他们考虑。经过13个小时的审议，陪审团裁定劳拉胜诉。他们将劳拉遇袭的一半责任归咎于骗子，另一半归咎于麦当劳。劳拉总共获得了610万美元的赔偿。其中包括110万美元的补偿性赔偿和500万美元的惩罚性赔偿。陪审团在裁决书附言中恳求麦当劳为员工提供更多关于性骚扰和诈骗电话的培训。后来有消息透露，陪审团之所以商议了这么久，是因为他们无法就劳拉应该获得多少金钱赔偿达成一致。一名陪审员希望判给她1亿美元，而另一名陪审员只想给她1美元。陪审团还判给唐娜·萨默斯110万美元。
Kim Dockery, the other assistant manager who had been on duty at the time of Laura's assault, was exonerated of any responsibility. Laura burst into tears upon hearing the verdict and hugged her mother and grandparents. She also embraced Donna Summers and the two expressed their happiness for each other. Laura later told the press that she planned to use the money to go to law school as her original college plans had been derailed by her assault. Her lawyer described the verdict as a complete rejection of McDonald's claim that they bore no responsibility to Laura or other employees who had been victims of the strip search scams. Donna Summers told the media, It was never about the money. It was about getting the truth out that McDonald's knew all along what was going on. This was a complete vindication. McDonald's issued a statement that they would be considering whether or not to appeal the finding and noted,
金·多克里是劳拉遇袭时在场的另一位副经理，她被宣告无罪并免除了所有责任。劳拉听到裁决后失声痛哭，拥抱了她的母亲和祖父母。她还拥抱了唐娜·萨默斯，两人为彼此感到高兴。劳拉后来告诉媒体，她计划用这笔钱去读法学院，因为她最初的大学计划因那次遇袭而毁了。她的律师将该裁决描述为对麦当劳“他们对劳拉或其他作为搜身骗局受害者的员工不承担任何责任”这一说法的彻底否定。唐娜·萨默斯告诉媒体：“这从来都不是为了钱。这是为了把真相说出来——麦当劳从一开始就知道发生了什么。这是一种彻底的平反。”麦当劳发表声明称，他们将考虑是否对裁决提出上诉，并指出：
As we've stated previously, this malicious hoax was perpetrated by individuals who do not represent our brand. What happened to Laura Fletcher was wrong and should never happen to anyone. McDonald's soon lodged an appeal. More than two years later, the Kentucky Court of Appeals ruled that they were upholding the jury's decision. A three-judge panel found that McDonald's legal department had been fully aware of the scammer, but made a conscious decision not to train or warn employees or managers about the calls. Despite upholding the decision, the judges deemed that the jury's sum awarded to Donna Summers had been excessive. Her payout was reduced from $1.1 million to $500,000. McDonald's was also ordered to pay a further $2.4 million in attorney fees for Laura. Laura, who had since become a mother, did not attend the appeal in person. Instead, one of her lawyers spoke to the media on her behalf stating that she was thrilled to learn of the verdict. McDonald's then decided to appeal the decision at Kentucky's Supreme Court. In 2010, while this petition was still pending, Laura settled with the company for an undisclosed amount, and McDonald's withdrew their second appeal. The case has drawn comparisons to a famous experiment conducted in the early 1960s by Yale University social psychologist Stanley Milgram.
“正如我们之前所说，这场恶毒的骗局是由不代表我们品牌的个人所策划的。发生在劳拉·弗莱彻身上的事情是错误的，绝不应该发生在使用我们品牌的任何人身上。”麦当劳不久便提起了上诉。两年多后，肯塔基州上诉法院裁定维持陪审团的决定。由三名法官组成的小组裁定，麦当劳的法律部门完全清楚骗子的存在，但却做出有意识的决定，不培训或警告员工或经理防范这些电话。尽管维持了原判，法官认为陪审团判给唐娜·萨默斯的金额过高。她的赔偿金从110万美元减至50万美元。麦当劳还被命令支付劳拉另外240万美元的律师费。此后已为人母的劳拉没有亲自出席上诉。相反，她的一位律师代表她向媒体发言，称她得知裁决结果后欣喜若狂。随后，麦当劳决定向肯塔基州最高法院对该判决提起上诉。2010年，在上诉仍在审理期间，劳拉与该公司达成了一笔未公开金额的和解，麦当劳也撤回了他们的第二次上诉。这起案件让人联想起20世纪60年代初由耶鲁大学社会心理学家斯坦利·米尔格拉姆（Stanley Milgram）进行的一项著名实验。
In the experiment, Professor Milgram told his subjects that he was researching learning. What he was really studying was people's willingness to obey authority. Participants were asked to administer electric shocks at an ever-increasing voltage to another individual whenever that person answered a question incorrectly. The individuals on the receiving ends of the shocks were in fact actors who were not harmed at all. The experiment found that the majority of participants were willing to administer the electric shocks, even if they felt extremely upset about having to do so. In 1971, Stanford University Professor Philip Zimbardo carried out a similar study, which came to be known as the Stanford Prison Experiment. His college student participants were split into two groups and were either assigned the role of a prison guard or an inmate. Professor Zimbardo's aim was to investigate the psychological effects of perceived power. The students embraced their roles, and the guards soon became authoritative and alarmingly abusive towards the inmates.
在这项实验中，米尔格拉姆教授告诉他的受试者他正在研究学习过程。而他真正研究的其实是人们服从权威的意愿。当另一个人回答问题错误时，参与者被要求向其施加电压不断升高的电击。接受电击的那些人实际上是由演员扮演的，根本没有受到任何伤害。实验发现，大多数参与者都愿意实施电击，即便他们为此感到极其苦恼。1971年，斯坦福大学教授菲利普·津巴多（Philip Zimbardo）进行了类似的研究，也就是后来为人熟知的“斯坦福监狱实验”。他招募的大学生参与者被分成两组，分别扮演狱警或囚犯的角色。津巴多教授的目的是调查人们对感知权力的心理影响。学生们很快就进入了角色，狱警们也变得极具权威性，并对囚犯们进行了令人震惊的虐待。
The experiment was abandoned after just six days. Professor Zimbardo was later hired as a consultant by one of the fast-food chains that was targeted by the strip search scammer. He suspected that the person responsible had read up on Milgram's work and described him as, very skilled in human psychology. Since mid-2004, there have been no further reports of a self-identified police officer calling fast-food restaurants to demand employee strip searches. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
仅仅六天后，实验就被叫停了。津巴多教授后来被受搜身骗局目标之一的某家快餐连锁店聘为顾问。他怀疑幕后黑手曾读过米尔格拉姆的著作，并形容此人“精通人类心理学”。自2004年中期以来，再也没有接到自称警察的人打电话给快餐店要求对员工进行搜身检查的报告。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。